my name is imani lewis and i play
calliope burns and i'm sarah catherine
hook and i play juliette paramount and
we're with buzzfeed to see how well we
really know each other
so the first question is what is your
birthday your birthday is april 12th
1999. your birthday is april 21st
and i don't know the year it's finally
you got the date all right
great the first time we've met so the
first time we met virtually was over
face time but the first time we met
officially
was oh when we first got to the hotel
and you were like oh my god you're so
much smaller
and you're like
a basketball player that was funny oh
their first job either acting or not
we'll do acting yours was the get down
yeah that's my first job my mind was a
soda stream yes yeah
sodastream commercials yeah
their favorite scene you filmed together
on first kill
your favorite scene is the pantry series
that's my favorite scene and yours is
the bee scene i love the beast
yeah we did that in our chemistry region
and that was chefs
their giveaway that they're about to
bring a character and start laughing so
truly the last
time we filmed together oh my god
having lunch at 4am
that's our lunch
and we had gyros and
you came back i couldn't remember
we are crying laughing like everyone was
so dead silent on set waiting for us to
get through this and it was such a
serious scene yeah but those gyros threw
okay
i'm sorry i just said gyro and i forgot
all my lines
oh yes i had a gyro and it just forgot
all my lines
it was one of the funniest yes so
probably lunch yeah if it's gyro lunch
it's usually lunch that makes us foggy
yeah favorite snack from crafty
we have a range of snacks we have a
brain
like i could list a lot of things yeah
i mean and beverages yeah i love lacroix
we love lacroix
lacroix i literally have one right down
there
oh
she got me one actually
um
you love
twizzlers love twizzlers you love veggie
straws love veggie strawberries
fruit snacks whether that's welch's or
moths yeah and then you also love juice
like you love i feel like you like
cranberry juice i love cranberry juice
like i feel like that's that's something
yeah you love lacroix i love la croix
there's these bars where it's like like
sea salt and like chocolate oh yeah yeah
yeah the rx parts yeah yeah
that was my
that was definitely yeah you like fritos
i know i never would get the bag
themselves and then i'd be like honey
i would never actually get my own i was
always feeling yours yeah of the tv
series or movie of all time
so we read we were bookies like we
we said that in the beginning yeah yeah
so
i mean we love tv as well yeah we love
tv television
oh
okay yeah i do tell me yours i'll talk
so i just i love the harry potter series
and i read all of the books and i just i
thought the movies were so well done
mine is gone girl oh nuts
yeah gone girl was amazing it's bananas
yeah that's one of my favorite like i
think it just had me like this oh yeah
it was intense yeah but i think favorite
like film of all time probably scarface
oh yeah real good okay yeah all right
like that okay well so that's the one
that we have unchecked right now so
we've gotten them all over that their
coffee order yes if you're having a
really long day it's just straight black
coffee yeah that's true that is true
yeah but if it's like regular regular
you like like with it just open oatmeal
just oat milk yeah you got it and you
don't drink coffee i don't i don't drink
coffee you were like i eat sugar right i
like the stuff give me sugar
we use it so many different ways imani
likes to say oh frick yeah i go off
yeah
that's a brick yeah but no it's
definitely there's something really
satisfying about the word yeah you can
use it so many different ways yeah i'm
from new york so it's out of here
so we got that right oh and finally the
actor they would love to work with in
the future i know yours is denzel
washington and yours is emma stone
that's right mm-hmm that's right
yay we did it you know my results
we did pretty well
we got ten nine out of ten yeah it was
and honestly that one was hard because
yeah neither there you guys even knew
that
yeah yeah yeah i said book two film yeah
all gone yeah yeah
harry potter yeah 100 p
be sure to go watch first kill on
netflix thank you buzzfeed bye
[Music]
you